thank you I'm really happy to be here a
couple of preliminary remarks before I
really get going one is Jennifer I think
you should not turn in early tonight you
should stay out because my experiences
those presentations go much better if
you have less sleep so that would be my
advice the second thing I would say is
that I
I truly identify with this group as I
told Brian earlier my my older brother
is and has been for about 25 years a
high school social studies and civics
teacher was a principal of his high
school for a long while stepped back a
couple years ago to devote himself just
to teaching and he for almost all those
years has every spring brought about
forty kids from his high school here to
Washington for a week and I've never
known whether to admire his courage or
questioned his sanity and doing that but
it's a great thing to see and it's a
great career and it's a great thing to
do and I admire what you do and I admire
what he does and I'm happy you're all
doing it and from speaking for myself
there's that nothing I could do in
Washington that would give me more
pleasure than speaking at an event for
c-span for Brian and for Susan both good
friends of long-standing and for those
of us of a certain age and Brian's right
I am of a certain age in Washington
c-span holds a place that really is near
and dear in our hearts because before
anybody realized what cable TV could do
for political debate in America c-span
saw it and acted before anybody could
use new technology and new media to
pollute and distort that political
debate Brian showed us all how to do it
right and now two decades later c-span
still does it right it's needed as an
alternative and as an antidote to what
has become a pretty skewed and often
one-sided political ranting that you can
find on the internet and elsewhere in
the country and so in my view the c-span
mission is more vital than ever and I'm
happy to just take this moment to say
thank you to c-span and Brian and
and on a more personal note back when
I'd never literally never before sat in
front of a TV camera and said a word
Brian lamb invited me to come on c-span
and talk for an hour on the Washington
journal I was petrified I'm pretty sure
c-span viewers were petrified but it
worked somehow and since then I've done
a lot of TV I have in a relationship at
the Wall Street Journal for years with
CNBC now with Fox Business Network for
four years I did a spot on CNBC every
morning at 6:15 in the morning and that
getting up early to come in and do
Washington Journal came in a really
handy and so I've come back and done
Washington Journal occasionally ever
since but I've never gotten over one
feeling that I have when I do this show
and when you're sitting there at 7:00
a.m. on the studio over there in Forth
capital and a call comes in from Hawaii
you're wondering what time is it in
Hawaii and why is this person calling
and why are you letting him speak on the
air there's no good answer to any of
those but and also here's a little
footnote to c-span history which I don't
think I've ever shared with Brian but
I'll divulge for the first time tonight
my own first experience in Washington
came earlier than that it came in 1978
when I came to Washington as a college
intern for a semester for a congressman
from Louisiana and Gillis long who you
will remember was a good guy of
now-deceased
one of the long famous long family of
Louisiana at the time I came congressman
long was a senior Democrat a senior
ranking member on the House Rules
Committee and at that point the question
of whether to put TV cameras into the
house was really coming to a boil in the
prevailing view among the veteran
members of the House leadership
including Gillis Long's that they would
never let that happen so one of my more
substantive duties as an intern for
congressman long was to write a draft of
a magazine article in his name arguing
against putting TV cameras in the house
so Brian I apologize for that but I do
want to say and this is the honest truth
that even as I wrote that argument
against the idea I thought to myself
this argument does not make very much
sense or at a minimum I don't agree with
it but I did it and now you know Brian
and I obviously wasn't very persuasive
because within two years of my writing
that piece for Gilles long c-span was in
fact broadcasting live from the floor of
the house and democracy is much much
better off for it and a lot of ways I
feel my own career has tracked the
history of c-span pretty effectively I I
came to Washington in 1980 c-span was
launched in 1979 I covered politics
defense foreign policy and then Barbara
Chaffetz my wife and I went overseas to
cover the Middle East as the two-person
husband and wife Middle East Bureau of
the Wall Street Journal for four years
or so and I had that interesting little
experience in Iran that Brian referred
to and we covered the whole region from
North Africa across the Persian Gulf and
it was kind of wild sometimes I got
thrown in prison barb was bombed by
American jets in Libya and it was great
and after that excitement if you're
young and you want to be a foreign
correspondent being bombed is not a bad
thing
after that died down a bit I returned to
Washington covered the first President
Bush's White House then the State
Department then became a political
writer and political editor and
ultimately deputy Washington bureau
chief and finally bureau chief for The
Wall Street Journal here I'm one of
those pathetic people that's a life raft
worked for one company my entire career
so I'm the world's most boring guy in
that respect but they've been good to me
and it's it's been a great organization
and now my job is Executive Washington
editor and that's my son calling on that
right now sorry I'm supposed to tell you
guys to turn your cellphone's off
understand all right
that won't happen it's one of my
reporters actually and I resume writing
a weekly column of the journal which is
the most fun you can have indoors I
think and I'm overseeing the journals
online political coverage which is sort
of expanded my own view of what a
multimedia president
is really like and overseeing
investigative reporting from Washington
along the way in that sort of long
winding history of reporting for the
journal most of it from Washington that
I began to feel that somewhere in all of
that there was the material to write a
book that had been accumulating inside
and was waiting to come out but never
really found its way into print and then
about two and a half years ago the
opportunity came an agent in Washington
rapes a Galen who's the best in town in
my opinion came to my colleague at the
journal then John Harwood and said he
thought it was time for a successor
volume to a book called the power game
which was written in the 1980s by a
terrific journalist Hedrick Smith about
how Washington worked in those days and
what I think of as the Reagan era and
John and I had talked sporadically about
doing a book together and so he john
enlisted me in the idea and we in turn
took the proposition to Kate Medina
who's a world-class editor at Random
House who happens to have been the
editor on the original power game book
and she loved that book then and does
now and loved the idea of doing a
successor book so Random House bought
the idea and the book that Brian showed
you all that you all get as a result of
that now the power game still stands up
very well over the years but the reality
is that a lot of the wiring in this town
had subsequently been ripped out and
redone since that book was written and
the capital has gone from Democratic
dominance to split between Republican
dominance and Democratic dominance and
back to Democratic dominance and back to
a split again which is where we are now
and along the way most of the inside
players have given away to new
generation of inside players some well
known and some not so well known and
what we hope to do in that in this book
was to capture those changes and
introduce readers to a sampling of some
of the more interesting folks that we've
come to know in our combined
half-century of reporting experience in
Washington but we wanted to do something
more along the way as well the
overarching mission of the book from our
point of view at least was to explain
what Washington has become in the
generation that I've been here why it's
become that way and whether frankly
there's any hope in turning it into a
more
productive place now let me explain a
little bit Washington today is stuck in
a state of gridlock and partisan warfare
that you've all heard about and you've
seen and that's become debilitating as
we say in the book near the front
simply put Pennsylvania Avenue doesn't
work very well these days so why is that
the case
well there's a confluence of forces that
make it that way
and let me tick off a few of them for
you first the center of the political
spectrum the political middle has become
a very lonely place in Washington in the
last generation it used to be that you
could find in that political middle a
kind of human bridge between the two
parties and between conservatives and
liberals a generation ago there was a
long Pennsylvania Avenue a healthy
contingent of southern conservative
Democrats and moderate or liberal
Northeastern Republicans and these
people were kind of the connective human
tissue between the two parties and
between the ideological extremes
nowadays most of those conservative
Southern Democrats have become
Republicans and those moderate
northeastern Republicans have approached
extinction and as a result the two
parties have sorted out and they've
moved to opposite sides of the political
spectrum and Democrats are now more
reliably liberal and Republicans are
more reliably conservative while that
has gone on the political system has
actually worked to encourage this kind
of partisan and ideological polarization
liberals get rewarded for being liberal
conservatives get rewarded for being
reliably conservative and nothing drives
them to the middle nothing makes this
more of the case from the modern art of
read or redrawing congressional
districts both parties in your states
and all over the country are complicit
in drawing up every 10 years
ideologically homogeneous districts that
produced that protect the party that
controls the district and produced the
incumbents who keep those seats forever
and ever
liberals in Congress are grouped with
liberal voters back home conservatives
with conservatives minorities with
minorities now the successful politician
in this system does not really have to
reach out to anybody unfamiliar to them
to keep his or her job
and you have as a result the House of
Representatives that's filled to a large
degree with people who don't have to
reach out across the partisan divide or
move to the middle for survival
here's a good illustration of this
California obviously the largest state
in the Union has 53 seats in the house
in the elections of 2002 and 2004 not a
single one of those seats changed party
hands in a 2006 which is a big election
that everybody felt was an earthquake
because it moved power from the
Republicans to the Democrats exactly one
seat in California changed partisan
hands put another way that means there's
less than a 1% chance in any given
election year that the party that
controls the seat in the state of
California will lose control of that
seat now at the same time that's going
on the parties have moved apart
ideologically and they've managed to
split power almost evenly among
themselves in the process you now have
in the house you have the house in the
hands of the Democrats the White House
in the hands of Republicans and a Senate
that split 49 to 49 with two
independents who hold the balance of
power and an environment in which power
is that evenly divided nobody is really
in charge of anything meantime the
atmosphere of Washington has changed as
well in ways that work against the
forging of compromise or the building of
consensus most significantly fewer and
fewer people in Congress actually live
here in Washington where they might
develop deeper relationships with people
from across the aisle get to know them
in a more human way and have the kind of
natural human activity that produces
compromise or consensus or at least
understanding what happens now is that
members of Congress because you know
modern travel and modern
telecommunications make it possible show
up in Washington work three or four days
a week
rush back to Reagan National Airport and
get out of town head home to either work
with constituents or equally often to
raise money for the next election in
that environment they don't get to know
each other and don't get to understand
each other here's an example John when
we were doing the book we had dinner
with John Dingell who's been in the
house himself for half a
three and whose father was in the house
before that he told us that when he was
first elected to the house from Michigan
the only way for the entire Michigan
delegation to get to Washington was to
endure either a 12-hour car ride or a 12
hour train ride from Michigan to
Washington and nobody obviously wanted
to do that too often so they lived in
Washington they lived in Washington with
their families who moved here when they
were elected they got to know each other
they got to understand each other
Democrat and Republican alike
now John Dingell tells us that doesn't
happen people simply don't know each
other another factor I have to admit is
the media echo chamber that's basically
turned into a 24/7 exercise in which
loud voices speaking to one side or the
other of the partisan divide can drown
out objective information in the middle
and make cooler analysis go to the back
of the room
the median environment is a cacophony
now and even the bully pulpit of the
White House is not enough to be heard
over the roar in many cases Elliott
Abrams who worked in the Reagan
administration in the 1980s and who
works in the bush White House now told
us when we were talking to him for the
book that in the Reagan White House in
the 1980s the place virtually shut down
between 6:30 and 7:30 every evening so
that everybody could watch the evening
news on the three networks that really
mattered ABC NBC and CBS the message
from those networks was that important
to everybody in the White House now
Elliott told us he almost never watches
the evening news anymore it just doesn't
matter there are so many other news
outlets and there's so much noise during
the day that there is no central
repository for information at the end of
the day it just doesn't work that way
right now
there is cable news networks that are
broadcasting news all day long I have a
website that's putting news out all day
long there's talk radio there's internet
news sites is a totally different media
environment which is all basically good
if you're in news business you have to
admire that the troubling part though is
that this isn't just a more cluttered
environment it's an environment that
allows people now mostly through the
internet to go to places to find news
that's slanted to the way they hope the
news
is rather than the way it really is
people are using the internet and radio
talk shows and other new media to
reinforce their preconceived notions
rather than to confront information that
may challenge those notions and that I
think is dangerous for individuals and I
think is somewhat dangerous for society
beyond all those causes of gridlock and
partisan warfare the negative question
that John and I were thinking about was
this as anybody in Washington actually
figured out how to work around these
problems whose figured out how to get
some things done and how do they do it
how in other words are people up and
down Pennsylvania Avenue figuring out
how to cope in this environment and and
this is the crucial question can anybody
do anything to change that environment
and won't anything happen in this
election to change that environment so
those are the big trends that we wanted
to write about now the question we had
and I suspect you can all identify with
this question was how do we write about
those issues in a way that connects with
average people who don't spend all their
days the way we do obsessing about
politics well maybe you do I don't know
but what John and I've learned as
journalists is what you probably all
learned as teachers when you tell
stories people listen if you have a
point to make it's much more likely to
get through what its embedded inside a
good story so that's what we tried to do
in this book as I tell Brian John I both
have pretty busy day jobs and so I when
we greeted to this book I said you know
what kind of busy most of the day how we
can actually do this and he said here's
my strategy we'll go out to lunch
everyday with somebody we think is
really interesting we'll interview them
and then we'll come back and write down
what they say and that's how we'll do
the book and that's pretty much how we
did the book I recommend it highly
we try to tell the stories of several
dozen people up and down Pennsylvania
Avenue some of them I Karl Rove and Bob
Strauss pretty well known names and some
I think equally are more interesting a
lot less well-known names to show how
this environment affects people trying
to get things done we've simply tried to
tell their stories or let them tell us
their stories to make the analysis of
the problems I just discussed come to
life a little bit more so for example we
tell the story of Kendu Burstyn who was
once the White House chief of staff for
Ronald Reagan and who now is runs a
consulting firm a Democrat in Republican
joined equally to try to help big
companies figure out how to get some
things done in Washington and who is
actually one of the few heavy hitters
around town who seems able to reach out
to Democrats and Republicans alike we
tell about Sam Brownback
senator from Kansas my home state I have
known for a while he's very much a
social conservative but we talked about
how Sam would like to reach beyond looks
for ways to reach beyond the partisan
divide on issues such as the
rehabilitation of prisoners sex
trafficking around the world even
abortion which is the resort of the red
light issue for both sides of the of the
social debate and sam asks himself i
think abortion should be illegal
many people think abortion rights should
be retained i don't think we're going to
resolve the debate over roe versus wade
any time soon maybe left and right
Democrat and Republican can get together
and agree on some steps that might make
abortion less common while agreeing to
disagree on the question of legality we
talk in the book about Charlie Rangel a
liberal african-american from New York
and Jim McCrery a conservative white
from Louisiana the top Democrat and the
top Republican on the House Ways and
Means Committee and how they decided
between themselves over some turtle soup
of all things a Jimmer Curry's office to
try to make a personal pact to get
beyond these divides and get some things
done on their very important committee
and they had a little success on trade
and on the minimum wage but mostly these
two well-intentioned guys found a lot of
frustration along the way tilting
against these windmills we tell the
story of Elliott Abrams who I mentioned
before
who's seen foreign-policy go from a
subject that was Trant that transcended
partisan divides to one that's now as
much a part of the partisan debate as
any domestic issue we tell the story of
Mara Vanderslice who's a young committed
social activist a liberal and a hunger
fighter who has made it her mission in
life to try to convince Democrats that
they can talk about they can talk about
religion and faith in campaigns and not
just cede that turf to the Republicans
so in some the fun thing about this book
was that we found all these people some
of whom John I have known for a long
long time some of whom we met along the
way didn't know at all previously to be
interesting and yes even fun people to
talk with and I know that's counter to
the image of Washington I certainly
apologize for that but our hope our hope
here is the people who read the book
will agree and yes I hope you all can
agree we'll even find it a little bit
educational so that's how the book came
about and I appreciate you're all paying
some attention to it thanks for
listening and I'm happy to just take
some questions now thank you yeah I
think you have to wait for a microphone
I mean I'm a responsible emcee how is
the Wall Street Journal responding to
the general pressures on all of print
media yeah and I asked that in the
context of what's happening with the
Tribune Company well first of all I'd
like to shout out to whoever's here from
Australia because I'm big on Australians
right now since Rupert Murdoch and News
Corporation have bought The Wall Street
Journal which is actually part of the
answer to your question um look there's
enormous financial pressures on the
industry particularly the newspaper
industry but in all media we're hardly
immune from them the luxury that we have
is that the journal was bought some
months ago by News Corporation and
Rupert Murdoch and who's made a
commitment to investing in the paper so
we're actually building up we have this
in this really convenient and I would
say unique problem in our Washington
bureau which is we have hired enough new
people that we don't have
for them all to sit at so I'm definitely
a counter-trend example what we'll see
how long we can continue that I think
the I think the transition that the
business is in is one from obviously and
this is a painful statement of the
obvious but from a print dominated model
it's one that will be something else I
don't think the desire for information
then the appreciation for objective and
accurate information has diminished in
the country at all
I think it's as high as ever and a lot
of it has simply moved to other places
and we have to get to those places we
have to be there with the information I
mean if you I'll tell you a story I
wrote up I read a column every week and
I wrote a column and I think it was the
night of super the Super Tuesday
primaries which I didn't remember what I
said but it was I thought it was fine
and I got it was published in the
journal the next day and it got you know
a fair amount of reader reaction I was
sitting at my desk in the middle of the
following afternoon and all of a sudden
email started to come in while I was
sitting I was doing something else and
they came in I mean you know I mean by
50 60 a minute because what rolling
through and I felt what happened here
you know what what something's going on
and so I started to call it to New York
to find out what why am I getting this
massive reaction to this column that was
actually printed you know put online 12
hours ago well what happened was that
Yahoo News had posted my column a link
to my column atop the Yahoo news page on
the Internet and that posting drove
650,000 views or so to the to the comp
so there is an enormous amount of power
there's a first of all there's an
enormous amount of appetite for
information there's an enormous amount
of power in that information it just has
to be harnessed and I think the question
for our industry is whether we can get
from where we've been where the industry
was when I started to where we need to
be and survive financially in the
interim you probably have a much better
answer that Bob than I do but that's my
view so Susan let me actually connect
that because that interest suggest that
there's a populace out there that cares
very much about issues you've described
a paralyzed polarized Washington
so put those two story sure well that's
that's the interesting thing about 2008
and that's the the backdrop of the book
in some ways is will this election
change the way this place works my view
quaint though it may be is that voters
actually have something to say about
this and that they they're starting to
speak I mean if they are saying
essentially we're not happy with the
status quo and I don't think it's a
coincidence that you have as your two
nominees for president this year John
McCain and Barack Obama two people whose
basic identity is that they are not part
of the system that I just described that
John McCain is seen as a rebel within
the Republican Party and Barack Obama
has described himself repeatedly as a
post partisan politician who's not
trapped in these baby boom generation
debates between Newt Gingrich and Bill
Clinton about what they did during the
war in college campuses and who inhaled
and who didn't then that that we ought
to get beyond all that and those are the
two most successful politicians in the
country this year if you think about the
presidential campaign so I also think by
the way Susan that there are a couple of
models out there now for a different
kind of governance there you have in New
York City Michael Bloomberg who is
running the city as a mayor who is it
used to be a Democrat it used to be a
Republican is now a declared and about
independent and on the other coast you
have Arnold Schwarzenegger who while
he's still a Republican essentially made
his own declaration of independence two
years ago when he get won his second
term and said I'm running the state my
way and people like that people say both
those politicians are doing pretty well
and are pretty popular and I think in a
way voters have a chance this year to
sort of make a statement about what
they're looking for and we'll see but I
do think it's I do think it's noteworthy
that the two candidates are people who
stand up in stand for a different model
of governing I'm sorry what they're and
then over here good the Internet to me
is amazing and how it is beginning to
shape the political arena I know an
Alabama unitary Everett is retiring and
we've had a Republican runoff just
recent little of this past juicy and
between JLove and Harry and Smith and
Jay laws it was just every single day I
was getting emails from from his
campaign and it's amazing to me how you
know this internet and
in the way that they're using it
actually I think influencing voters I
mean what do you think about that I
think it is I think this is the you know
it's interesting you've covered national
politics that people wrote including me
in 2000 and in 2004 well the Internet's
really going to matter
well the Internet's really it didn't
really it didn't make a big impact it is
making a big impact this year and on a
lot of different levels it's is making
an impact on dissemination of
information it's making an impact in
political organization and we shouldn't
forget the biggest impact well I think
the biggest impact is making is it's in
change it's changed the campaign finance
system in a way that no legislation was
ever able to do Barack Obama has
essentially used the internet to create
an entirely new campaign finance system
he has organized a network of a million
and a half donors not big donors small
donors who give an average of about
ninety five dollars a piece and who have
made him by far the most well financed
candidate in the history of the country
well that's that's what campaign finance
reformers have essentially been trying
to do for 25 years and the Internet has
made it possible so I think this is the
OL and I don't know what what else is
going to change because of the internet
but this is the year I totally agree
with you in which it started to happen
I'm curious what your perspective or
suggestions would be as far as how we
can strike a balance of teachers and
then also just as citizens between the
well educated and credentialed writers
of the media and Billy Bob's blog and
yeah the Lehman's all the different
different sources of media a blog or two
I
I think that's think that's the key
question and I actually think to the
extent that you know that I want to be
an optimist I kind of think the reality
is that in the long run quality honesty
and objectivity will went out and I
think it's starting to happen a little
bit what you hope for if you're in my
business
is that people will gravitate toward
objective and well reported journalism
whether that's in print or online or on
fox businesses or however it's delivered
and that eventually people will start to
discriminate on line between you know
Billy Bob's blog or I would say more
precisely a news site that's a partisan
attack operation masquerading as a new
site and and start to sort that out and
now you're starting to see it I mean you
know the Wall Street Journal WJ calm is
the largest paid site on the internet
page views are just climbing through the
roof that doesn't mean anybody knows how
to exactly make a lot of money off of
those yet but traffic to what we're
doing on the online is going up in huge
lead by huge leaps and bounds so I think
my advice to you would be and this is
obviously I'm not an objective observer
and giving this advice but you know if
you wanted to direct your students and I
I would actually encourage you to do
this direct them to sort of establish
news organizations online sites because
the journalism standards that we if for
125 years have put into print in the
Wall Street Journal the same journalism
standards that we carry on to our online
product and that's true for other news
organizations and I think the kids you
teach just need to find us and need to
realize we're not we're doing something
different than Matt Drudge and maybe
something in the long run that might
even be more valuable and so I what
scares me is the the habits that are
being developed now by young readers
that don't recognize what I just said
but I think that it's probably in the
interest of all of us it's sort of
interest to if I was like finish my
career getting a paycheck every week to
get people to start moving in that
direction but I think I think it may be
starting to happen right there and then
I'll come back over here
one of those same lines I was talking to
my colleagues today and what do you
think the health of the newspaper
industry is with the number of
newspapers going down down down and a
lot of our students don't read
newspapers they live
listen to electronic media if anything
and I think it's been assessed that a
lot of the heavy lifting the initial
reporting is being led by print
journalists and then the electronic
journal is kind of pile on in in file
suit they really don't do the initial
investigative in-depth reporting
I think you've described a lot of the
dynamic I mean the the original
reporting is tends to be done by
traditional mainstream news I mean
mainstream media has become by the way a
pejorative online mainstream media's is
not a compliment but that's where the
original reporting tends to happen and a
lot of the rest of the buzz on the
Internet is derivative of that I mean I
go I start my day every day at 5:00 a.m.
by going online and reading things for
for the for an aggregation we do every
day of political analysis on the web and
a lot of it is driven by what's in print
again that's you know I think that's a
problem
right now but I also think it suggests
that sort of a emergence of quality will
happen over over time you know I I think
that the people who still have though
we're all strapped financially I think
the people who have the resources to do
real reporting are still traditional
news organizations I personally don't
care whether people read that you know
on a piece of paper or on a computer
screen why should I care it's a lot
cheaper to deliver whatever I write to
you on a computer screen than it is to
you know put it on a piece of paper
print it out put on a truck burn the gas
to drive the truck so it could be in
your driveway I mean it but it doesn't
matter I think the key is where people
turning for news and I think that has
more to do with the quality of the
product rather than the delivery vehicle
for giving it to you
okay and then it here and then they're
given the changes that our industry has
created and the ability to influence
policy like I think about for example
like lifetime networks and all the work
that they've done to be able to help
pass legislation that benefits women the
internet what if you had to write this
third saga to your book and third
element of the book in this two-part
chain
20 years from now what given the trend
line and what and usually I think you
mean in politics yeah I mean politics if
you look at I think in our industry the
potential to shape policy and yet with
the tools that we've created and deliver
into the home and I think we haven't
seen the tip of the iceberg in terms of
where I'm headed and then really the
localization on the grassroots movement
you know I think the Obama's campaign is
kind of starting to really open that up
if you had to write your next series in
this year books you know what let's say
if it was in 20 years where yeah it's
really that's really intriguing question
I mean I guess my the first thing I'd
say is I would guess that you'll have a
altom utley a better informed electorate
and I would guess the partisan tides of
voters would be even looser than they
are now they're not that great now in
most states the fastest growing segment
of the population is political
independence which is another reason why
the voters may be pushing politicians
back toward the middle I think the the
you know the history of parties in this
country is that people weren't quite
sure who to vote for they pull a
straight line because you could be trust
the Democrats you trust the Republicans
because you don't really know
well people now know you know they know
a lot and they're going to know a lot
more and so I would guess party
affiliation will matter a little bit
less and I would guess that probably
what we do as a filterable matter a
little bit less now the caveat to that
is that I do think you know the flip
side of a lot of information is too much
information
you know deluge and if you think about
journalism what journalism really is
about is sorting through the information
on behalf of the reader or the or the
viewer and sifting it out and deciding
what's important in presenting it in a
in a digestible package for people who
don't want to wade through the ocean
every day I think that function will
become more important not less over time
and that's partly the answer to your
question as well and so I think there
still will be a kind of a media filter
but I think that the by kids are going
to expect to be able to go online and
find out for themselves and they're
going to do that and I don't think
that's a bad thing for democracy it's a
it's a town hall really and that's not I
don't pretend that that's a bad thing I
just I just think it's different I think
it makes people think for themselves
which is good and I think our role is
going to be to help people sort of find
their way through what is an insert of
an ever larger sea of information okay
right right there earlier in the
introduction it was just briefly
mentioned about your arrest in Tehran
and I was just wondering if you could
just give us a little bit more insight
regarding the circumstances we are in
that and kind of your experiences sure
well it was memorable what happened was
in I was based in Cairo in the Middle
East and and Iran was a very difficult
place to get to because the Iranians are
not we're not Danone are not now really
good to have American journalists
bopping around town but I got a visa to
go to Iran along with about 10 other
American journalists and some West
European journalists because the
Iranians at that point we're fighting
the iran-iraq war against Saddam Hussein
and had some big successes on the
southern battlefield they wanted
journalists in to show him what happened
and and to get you know to have a
legitimate looted legitimate news
organizations tell the world about what
they were accomplishing on the
battlefield so we've went to Iran we
flew down to the southern battlefield
you know dodge bullets dodge missiles
and survived to tell the story and I
thought wow this has been great now
leave town but what happened one night
was that as we were two days I think
before we were scheduled to leave I was
this funny thing started to happen
strange people started following me
around town and they the Iranians had
taken our passports because they needed
to extend our visa so we could actually
leave the country and they wouldn't give
me my past
back which is and honestly in three
years as a for as a foreign
correspondent and at least have the only
time I'd ever given anybody my passport
because one thing you want to have in
your hands is your passports you can get
out of Dodge if you need to well I
couldn't get out of Dodge in that case
and so it was clear that something was
up and and about 9 o'clock at night I
was walking through the hotel parking
line the car pulled up alongside four
guys jumped out dressed in camouflage
grabbed me pinned my arms behind my back
three in the back seat of the car face
down one of them jumped in on top of me
the rest of them slammed the door shut
and they took off driving wildly through
the streets of Tehran screaming at me in
Farsi which I don't speak a word of by
the way I spoke a little Arabic but no
Farsi they put a blindfold on me and
drove me around for a while and
ultimately ended up in heaven prison
which is where they take political
prisoners in Iran and they troop me
inside sat me down in the hallway I had
a blindfold on all this time and
eventually took me into an interrogation
room where a guy it's probably a little
older than me but not not much told me
that I was an Israeli spy and then I
they knew I was a spy I was being
arrested for it and I would just admit
my guilt and and get it over with and I
sort of said the obvious things not a
spy I'm a journalist your country
invited me in you gave me the visa you
know exactly who I am and so it went on
like that for a while and he said well
we'll talk about this tomorrow and they
took me away to another interrogation
room and close the door so so I spent
about four days in Evin prison
undergoing interrogation that sort of
went like that you know you're a spy no
I'm not a spy I'm a journalist you're an
Israeli Nam an American you've been to
Israel yes I've been to Israel every
time I write a story out of Israel the
Wall Street Journal prints three million
copies and distributes them around the
world so that's not exactly a secret yes
I've been to Israel and you know I went
through this good-cop bad-cop
interrogation in which the bad cop guy
would come in and sort of punch me in
the back a little bit and say it's going
to be very hard for you if you don't
just admit your guilt and I'd say no I'm
not going to do that and he would go
away and an hour later the good cop guy
would come in and say oh you know we
really don't want to hurt you but you
know you should just make it easy for
yourself so
that went on for a while and the whole
point of the exercise was that I was not
a journalist that I'm a spy and then
after about four days of this eventually
they moved me to a prison cell which was
not a lot of fun because honestly the
low moment was probably when I was in
the prison cell and I looked around and
looked on the wall and you know how on
the cartoons the prisoners are always
doing scratch marks like 1 2 3 4 5 once
it's the count that while they were
those scratch marks on the wall of this
cell and that was not a fun experience
so I just figured I'm going to be here
for a good long while and four days
later they came in and they said your
case all smiles and I said although I
actually couldn't see the smiles I was
blindfolded the whole time your case has
been successfully resolved you'll be
free to go tomorrow can we get you
anything good to eat in the meantime so
somehow along the way they had decided
that I was journalists not a spy and the
next day they did in fact take me to the
gate of the prison I got to the gate I
took off it was blindfold for the first
time since I was arrested because I
wanted to see these guys once at least I
turned to one of these guys who was my
interrogator he stuck out his hand and
he said I'm sorry about this do you have
a business card I'd like to call you if
I ever get to America so I gave him my
business card and he's never called so
you know who knows what happened I I've
heard various stories sense about why I
was arrested one story says that when we
were down at the war front I walked into
some map room and would look to be you
know sort of nosing around in ways that
were dangerous and subversive another
version the one I'm more inclined to
believe was that in the Iranian
government then as in the Iranian
government now there's a real split
between people who want to do business
with the west and people who have no
desire to do that and that the people
who were unhappy that a bunch of Western
journalists had been invited in in the
first place one of the grab one throw
him in jail and make a point that they
didn't think this was a sort of thing
the Islamic Republic should be doing and
that I just happen to be the lucky
choice but anyway it was it did make me
appreciate what the Wall Street Journal
and one of the reason I'm loyal to the
Wall Street Journal was it totally went
to bat for me moved heaven or State
Department White House
got the Vatican to having to be Catholic
got the Vatican to send my baptismal
certificate and the certificate that
said I was an altar boy when I was in
the fourth grade to the to the Iranian
ambassador to the United Nations and one
of those things work in Here I am today
so it's it is what happens in two
foreign correspondents it's not as sadly
it's not as unusual as you as you might
think it just happened to me my 15
minutes so thank you all very much great
smart